[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic
salze anéchoïque
l'air qui constitue notre atmosphère est
formé de molécules principalement du
diazote et du dioxygène
lorsqu'un objet vibre il déplace les
molécules et elle se poussent les unes
après les autres formant une onde qui se
propage dans l'espace c'est ce qu'on
appelle un son
mais que se passe-t-il lorsqu'un son
rencontre un obstacle
la vibration des molécules d'air va
tenter de pousser les molécules de
l'obstacle mais celles ci sont fortement
liés
l'obstacle est solide il est difficile
de le faire vibrer comme si elles
étaient reliés par des ressorts les
molécules de l'obstacle résiste et
repousse les molécules d'air dans
l'autre sens
l'undd parvient en partie à faire vibrer
l'obstacle et se transmet derrière lui
mais elle est également réfléchi une
partie de l'inde est renvoyé dans
l'autre sens c'est ce qu'on appelle un
écho
sur terre les ondes sonores sont
omniprésentes musique communications
transport qu'on le veuille ou non nous
baignons au quotidien dans une soupe de
son qui se superposent et rebondissent
sur tout ce qui nous entoure
imaginons un musicien qui joue de la
guitare dans une salle de concert
[Musique]
la musique se propage dans toutes les
directions et arrive aux oreilles du
public
mais le son rebondit sur les parois de
multiples fois et tous ces échos sont
également reçu par l'auditoire
leçon initial de la guitare est
brouillée par toutes ces ondes on parle
de réverbération
[Musique]
c'est ce qui différencie l'ambiance
d'une église
de celle d'un appartement
[Musique]
mais imaginons maintenant que dans un
but scientifique
nous voulions analyser le sang rayonné
par un objet par exemple les ondes
produites par un haut parleur
dans ce cas les réflexions du som pose
problème elle perturbe le signal que
l'on voudrait mesurer
pour isoler le son brut du haut parleur
il faudrait créer une pièce très
silencieuse vide et qui ne produisent
aucun écho une sale année coïc
dans cette vidéo nous allons tenter de
construire une sale année coïc étape par
étape
[Musique]
pour commencer rendons la pièce
parfaitement silencieuse au départ la
salle n'est pas silencieuse notre
ordinateur par exemple fait un peu de
bruit
une première amélioration serait de
déplacer le matériel de mesure dans une
autre pièce pour éviter qu'on ne
l'entende elle servira de salle de
pilotage
le silence n'est toutefois pas encore
parfait d'autres bruits proviennent de
l'extérieur les voitures les passants
les avions pour s'en affranchir on va
remplacer les parois par du béton très
épais que les ondes ont du mal à
traverser et on ajoute une couche
d'isolant acoustique un matériau très
efficace pour absorber les ondes sonores
le passage des camions ou des trains
provoque également des vibrations du sol
qui se répercute dans la pièce pour
s'isoler de ses vibrations on va à
surélever la structure et la placer sur
des plots anti vibratile de gros ressort
destiné à absorber les vibrations
enfin on construit une deuxième boîte
tout autour de la salle pour finir de
l'isoler complètement
cette épaisseur contribue notamment à
isoler la salle des variations de
température à l'extérieur
le son se déplace plus vite dans l'air
chaud car les molécules ils sont plus
agitée
si on imagine un jour en plein été les
bords de la salle risquerait de se
réchauffer par rapport au centre et les
ondes sonores si propagerait
différemment
en isolant la pièce on s'assure qu'elles
gardent une température homogène et que
les ondes se déplacent partout de la
même façon
à ce stade notre salle est très
silencieuse on l'a isolé de tous les
bruits parasites provenant de
l'extérieur mais il reste un problème
les ondes se réfléchissent toujours sur
les murs et brouillent le son que l'on
veut mesurer
pour régler ce dernier problème on va
surélever le haut parleur pour le placer
au centre de la pièce et recouvrir
toutes les parois par des centaines de
10 aidera ce sont des objets
triangulaire constitué d'un matériau
poreux idéal pour absorber les sons
quand une onde rencontre une paroisse
tous ces zigzags démultiplie la surface
de matériaux absorbants londe rebondi de
multiples fois piégé à l'intérieur de
ces structures et se dissipe de plus en
plus à chaque rebond
on a construit une sale année coïc
contrairement à une pièce classique
leçon s'y propage librement dans toutes
les directions et ne rencontre aucun
obstacle comme s'il s'agissait d'une
salle infiniment grande
au laboratoire de mécanique et
d'acoustique de marseille les chercheurs
acousticien dispose d'un équipement
unique un complexe originale de trois
grandes salles anéchoïque aux
performances exceptionnelles configurer
chacune pour des applications
différentes
la première salle du lma est dédié à la
perception auditive on y étudie le
système auditif humain cette salle est
spécialement conçu pour pouvoir placer
une personne ou un mannequin équipés de
micros au centre de la pièce la personne
est ainsi isolées de l'extérieur on
parle parfois de chambre sourde on y
étudie l'intelligibilité de la parole ou
notre perception du son en trois
dimensions on tente également de
caractériser n'ont ressenti en termes de
préférence ou de gêne face à différents
sons
ou encore notre perception de
l'intensité sonore
ou de la hauteur du son
ces travaux permettent de mieux
comprendre notre audition et son
fonctionnement
la deuxième salle du laboratoire est une
salle semi anéchoïque le sol n'est pas
absorbant le son peut s' y réfléchir
cette configuration est plus pratique
pour certaines applications de recherche
et pour les industriels on peut par
exemple poser de gros objets comme une
voiture ou une machine à laver et
mesurer l'intensité du bruit qu'ils
produisent en vue d'évaluer leurs
performances ou leur conformité en
termes de nuisances sonores
ses produits sont destinés à être
utilisés sur un sol et il est donc
judicieux de prendre en compte les
réflexions des ondes qui participe elle
aussi au bruit total qu'entendra
l'utilisateur
sous la salle une cabine communiquent
par une trappe et permettent également
de placer une source sonore pour mesurer
le son qui traverse un objet on peut de
la sorte déterminer si un matériau est
un bon isolant acoustique par exemple
enfin la troisième salle du laboratoire
très grande et très performante et
principalement dédiés à des projets de
recherche fondamentale et a pour
objectif d'y développer un système
unique au monde
lorsqu'on entend un son celui ci est
constitué de plusieurs fréquences
vibrant entre vingt et vingt mille fois
par seconde
les hautes fréquences correspond à des
sons aigus et les basses fréquences à
des sons plus graves
mais plus un son est grave plus sa
longueur d'onde est grande
et en dessous de 100 vibrations par
seconde la longueur d'onde dépasse
plusieurs mètres et lady and he sont
trop petits en comparaison ils ne
parviennent pas à piéger les ondes
sonores
les sons les plus graves rebondissent
sur les parois comme s'il s'agissait
d'une salle ordinaire
pour pallier ce problème et créèrent une
salle qui soit anéchoïque même pour les
fréquences basses
les chercheurs du lma travail sur le
développement d'un système unique au
monde l'idée est de compléter leurs
vêtements des parois par soixante quatre
haut-parleurs et 128 microphone destiné
à agir en temps réel pour annuler les
échos dans les basses fréquences
lorsqu'un sont graves rebondi contre une
paroi il est détecté par les microphones
qui ordonne aussitôt haut-parleurs de
produire une onde identique mais opposé
on contrôle activement les ondes qui
n'ont pas pu être absorbés
et on les annuler en leur superposant de
nouvelle onde opposé
on parle de contrôle actif le même
principe que dans les casques antibruit
si l'air vibre dans un sens le
dispositif va aussitôt réagir et pousser
les molécules dans l'autre sens pour
annuler leurs vibrations
ce projet très ambitieux est visible à
l'échelle internationale est pour
l'instant en cours de développement mais
la salle est déjà pré câblé pour
accueillir ce système et les chercheurs
ont franchi des étapes prometteuses dans
l'espoir d'une première mondiale
[Musique]
en résumé une sale année qu il remplit
deux fonctions elle crée un espace
silencieux isolées de l'extérieur et
minimise les réflexions du son sur ses
parois une telle salle est un équipement
de référence pour les acousticiens il en
existe d'ailleurs des analogues pour
étudier les ondes électromagnétiques
les trois salles du laboratoire de
mécanique et d'acoustique de marseille
répond à de multiples problématiques
scientifiques
on y étudie le rayonnement de sources
sonores complexe comme des instruments
de musique mais aussi le système auditif
humain et notre perception du sont
techniques on y caractérise leçon
rayonné par des objets industriels ou
encore la transparence acoustique de
certains matériaux innovants et des
problématiques de santé publique pour
étudier les nuisances et la pollution
sonore ou encore améliorer les
performances des implants cochléaires
destinés aux personnes atteintes de
surdité
contrairement à ce qu'on entend parfois
il est possible d'y rester plusieurs
heures sans problème c'est ce que font
les scientifiques lors de leur
expérience
mais certaines personnes peuvent être
sensibles et est troublé par ce silence
presque absolu
pour finir le lm à développe un système
unique au monde une sale année coïc
hybride qui sera doté d'un système de
contrôle actif dans l'espoir d' étudier
en temps réel des sources basses
fréquences chose impossible à l'heure
actuelle
cette vidéo a été réalisée en
partenariat avec ecoscience provence
alpes côte d'azur dans le cadre des
vidéos etc aux scientifiques elle a été
écrite en collaboration avec le
laboratoire de mécanique et acoustique
de marseille sous les conseils de cédric
pinède pour en savoir plus sur les
salles anéchoïque du lma rendez vous sur
la chaîne des consciences
[Musique]